[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain a chilean romantic
comedy film called ugly me
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
in the city of santiago chile lives an
astonishingly beautiful woman amanda she
works for an architectural firm and is
very good at her job one afternoon
amanda calls her boyfriend pablo she
wants to go to her friend fernanda's
birthday party together with him what
amanda doesn't know is that her
boyfriend is in fernanda's bedroom
cosplaying as a kitten as the two talk
over the phone fernanda distracts pablo
making him hang up in a hurry seconds
later they accidentally call amanda
again and she hears them moaning and
meowing it doesn't take her long before
barging into fernanda's house with a
shotgun upon realizing that they have
been caught pablo says that he was
kidnapped but amanda isn't naive enough
to believe him she shoots him in the
crotch ensuring that he never cheats on
anyone else again in the following scene
amanda is with a psychiatrist discussing
anger management she doesn't show any
regret about what she did in fact she is
confident that she would do it again if
she were in such a situation the
psychiatrist reveals that any person
with her level of anger issues must be
confined the information changes
amanda's opinion on everything and she
suddenly feels very sorry for what she
did she is let go after she makes the
doctor believe nothing of such sort is
going to happen again the case has made
it to the police and hence to amanda's
job she explains to her boss that she
was betrayed by two people she loved the
most he contemplates her position in the
company and decides to fire her in the
end amanda no longer wants to live in
santiago she packs her bags and moves to
the city of valparaiso her brother has
an empty house that she can stay in for
the next six months she is also
confident that she will get a decent job
in the city the only thing amanda is
worried about is being pursued by men
she doesn't want to date or fall in love
with anyone after what happened the last
time however an attractive young lady
like her is never left alone she goes to
the church to calm down and makes
friends with the pastor after telling
him of all her problems he also has no
immediate family members and lives on
his own he welcomes her to come to him
anytime she needs a friend to talk to at
home amanda goes through many job
vacancy advertisements in the newspaper
all of them have a requirement lower
than her qualification and experience
she picks one randomly which
coincidentally happens to be an
architectural firm like the one she used
to work in next she buys a fat bodysuit
ugly dentures and prosthetic makeup to
make herself look unattractive after
putting everything on she is
unrecognizable even to the people she
knew earlier in the following scene she
goes to the firm for an interview her
boss max asks her many questions and
finds out she has a husband and two sons
amanda believes that the husband's story
will make her lie more presentable and
reduce male advances max doesn't ask for
any authentication and hires her because
of the experience she possesses for the
first time in her life amanda feels
valid because she is sure that her
beauty didn't get her the job after that
max introduces her to the staff members
and their roles in the team first is a
married man named juan he has three kids
a full-time job and is studying to get
his master's degree then there is karen
a hot young office girl who does the
least work but is favored by everyone
because of her beauty that's just like a
karen lastly we are introduced to an
architect named marcelo he is the
typical womanizer who judges people
based on how attractive they are
marcelo's day-to-day life consists of
working and bringing home a different
woman every night he meets amanda for
the first time and is instantly repulsed
by her given her appearance amanda also
figures out what kind of man he is and
quietly curses his shallow thoughts the
two warned themselves to stay away from
each other unaware that destiny is about
to intertwine their paths in the first
meeting amanda is told about an old
telmax building that was recently
remodeled by their company they have
completed the project but there has been
some interference in the building's
internet service because of an unknown
problem with the structure amanda
instantly recognizes that it must be
because of a vp1 service problem karen
thinks that amanda's involvement with
the project will only create more
complications because she is new to the
job she wants to be the one to solve the
problem but max thinks otherwise karen
is dismissed which makes her despise
amanda instantly marcelo and juan are
asked to accompany amanda to the problem
site and help her the men are not happy
about being her assistants but they
oblige anyway in the following scene the
trees are on the terrace of the building
amanda is working hard to find the
problem while marcelo is busy boasting
about his sexual experiences to juan
amanda tells them the interference must
be coming from the railway station they
go to the location where marcelo and
juan continue their conversation while
amanda works she finally figures out
that the water channels that pass right
under the building are interfering with
the waves amanda and marcelo go to check
the water channel while juan stays to
monitor when the train departs marcelo
stays outside to check the frequency
leaving amanda to go into the channels
on her own she doesn't fit in between
one of the gates and takes off her fat
suit as the team is communicating
through walkie talkies amanda's device
stops working before she can get dressed
marcelo comes to see if she is okay
amanda quickly flashes her flashlight in
his face and says that she had to take
her clothes off so they wouldn't get
dirty fortunately for her marcelo turns
around and leaves after a successful day
at work the three go to a pub to have a
few drinks they drive amanda's car which
she has filled with children stuff to
make it look more realistic at the pub
marcelo yet again cracks sexual jokes
making the other two uncomfortable juan
leaves early to study leaving amanda and
marcelo behind once alone amanda calls
him out for being a shallow man marcelo
proudly agrees and claims that children
and marriage are the end of one's life
amanda feels bad for him because he will
never experience real friendship and
love one that lasts more than a single
night marcelo still describes his dream
girl's body and is unapologetically a
womanizer this infuriates amanda
reminding her of her ex-boyfriend even
when she is at home she cannot stop
thinking about his comments upon taking
the fat suit and wig off she sees that
she looks exactly like the dream girl he
described amanda makes it her mission to
teach marcelo a lesson and goes to the
club again this time dressed as her real
self when they meet marcelo instantly
feels attracted to her throughout the
night he tries taking her somewhere
private she leads him on and then
rejects him confusing him as to whether
she is interested or not in the end she
promises to meet him the next day and
leaves the following day amanda goes to
the pastor and tells him everything she
did the man tells her she is going to
regret last night because she will have
to tell him the truth one day either
that or she could just blow his dick off
with a shotgun however amanda is adamant
about wanting to teach marcelo a lesson
in the office marcelo brags about
meeting a girl in the club and her being
totally into him amanda knows he is
exaggerating but keeps it to herself in
the evening marcelo excitedly waits for
her to come to the club but after an
hour she texts him that she won't be
there the same thing happens the next
day after hours of waiting marcelo gets
it text saying they should meet at his
place tomorrow at work he brags to
amanda about the new girl who is so into
him that she is coming to his home at
night amanda smiles and listens to his
stories knowing very well that he is
lying marcelo buys takeout and puts it
on plates to pretend that he made it for
his date she soon arrives and starts
flirting with him after eating and
talking for a while things get steamy
marcelo is kissing her arm when she
stops him and says that she is going to
be late after she leaves he is left
confused because no woman has ever
treated him this way he pours his
frustrations onto amanda at work by now
he has started to see her as an actual
friend something he couldn't do with any
other woman in his entire life meanwhile
karen is burning in jealousy because she
has a crush on marcelo she spies on the
duo all the time to understand what they
are talking about later that day she
asks amanda about her children this
makes amanda realize that if she doesn't
show her children to the people they
will probably start suspecting her hence
she asks the pastor to arrange for two
little boys to come on a playdate with
her this is sus on many levels the next
day she brings them to the office and
proves that she is in fact a mother
surprisingly enough she sees marcelo
playing with the youngest kid he has
frequently described how much he hates
children which seems to have been a lie
at night amanda goes to his house for a
second date something about marcelo is
different this time he puts more effort
into getting to know her rather than
flirting eventually they go to his bed
and start making out things get heated
pretty soon but they come down in an
instant when marcelo doesn't get an
erection in the following scene marcelo
is telling amanda everything that
happened she suggests he put more effort
to impress the new girl like actually
cooking for her instead of ordering
takeout they then go to his house and
cook together this is the first time
marcelo has had a female friend come to
his house and he feels amazing about it
after eating they go to the terrace and
talk for a long time amanda declares
that marcelo is just afraid of
commitment and promises that he will
find love one day suddenly he leans in
and kisses her he apologizes right after
but they cannot deny the sparks they
feel in their hearts in the following
scene marcelo is with max talking about
his love life max asks him to close his
eyes and think of a woman marcelo
doesn't say who he saw but knows that
the girl is the love of his life later
that day amanda comes to his house for
the third date to her surprise marcelo
says that he is in love with her amanda
knows he is lying and is sad that he is
still the same person after everything
they talked about she makes him wear
women's clothes and cuffs his hands to
the bed frame but in contrast to what he
had expected she brings out a knife and
cuts his stomach a few hours later the
police arrive at the scene and let
marcelo free they realize that the blood
is fake and the woman just wanted to
scare marcelo the news makes it to the
television and marcelo is humiliated
amanda has taught him a lesson like she
wanted to but something doesn't feel
right to her when she tells the pastor
about this he declares that she is in
love with him when marcelo comes to the
office the next time he tells her that
he is a changed man now what happened to
him yesterday has made him realize that
she was right he has to start looking
for real love not just one night's
stance with that being said he goes out
with karen at night he arrives at
amanda's home drunk she keeps him from
seeing her and talks through the door
marcelo reveals that he proposed to
karen and is going to marry her this
week however he also reveals that he is
in love with amanda she is far from his
type of woman and is married but he
couldn't help but fall for her he knows
that she will never be his which is why
he is marrying karen both of them shed
tears and separate without saying
anything else then the day of the
wedding finally comes amanda and marcelo
meet outside the church amanda tries
telling him the truth but decides
otherwise they share an emotional hug
before the ceremony starts the priest
asks marcelo if he takes karen as his
lawfully wedded wife everyone waits for
his answer but it never comes suddenly
amanda sneezes and the fake dentures
fall out of her mouth marcelo takes her
wig off finally realizing the truth the
scene then cuts to a few years later
amanda and marcelo are married with
three children and a fourth one on the
way they live a happy life with their
family if this movie taught me anything
it's that misogynists and psychopaths
always finish first subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching